yeah that should be goofy bro the way
that [ __ ] work points is like i ain't
know what a point was for a long ass
time right
i used to be like you could have a point
i don't give a [ __ ] about no point like
you're only taking like no percentage of
all that you you can have a point points
is like percentages at the end of the
day same [ __ ] so it points so
in deals you got
100 points right you can say that
you might get a deal where you the label
give give you 15 points and they get the
85 you feel me and that's after you
recoup no hell that should be crazy so
it'd be like
out of that 15
all the bills was going to come out that
15. yeah like all the studio time well
they're going to give you an advance and
then that advances in advance on your 15
exactly so whatever you spend out of and
then whatever you spend out of your
budget comes out of that 15 percent and
then the 85 they take free and clear
yeah for sure and then this will [ __ ]
you up even more though is these points
that you'll be saying like oh you can
have a point because you're a producer
you did this but you could have a point
because you mixed it are you helping the
line or whatever so you go from 15
points you gave him two points now you
had 13. right
over here that helped you with the line
then you're at [ __ ] 12. and then that
[ __ ] go down you like look at you like
10 points and it's like now all the
money coming out of this 10 points
what the [ __ ] i thought i had 15 points
that should be crazy probably be like
that should get tricky that's why like
when artists take those big advances
like they really should try to make them
last because you have no i like you know
what i'm saying like they don't tell you
about none of that [ __ ] right
you [ __ ] broke you don't got nobody
around you that got no money neither so
you're the only [ __ ] with money
everybody looking at you now that should
be crazy like damn i don't even got no
money money literacy like i don't even
know what to do with this [ __ ] right
right